hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
[Music]
Hey I hope you enjoyed that that took a
lot of work to make and it probably
wasn't worth it but we're gonna continue
on anyway because this episode is all
about love believe it or not in the game
now is a way to get your rival to get
the [ __ ] out stop by without having to
murder them which is an interesting
prospect because as a normal Japanese
school girl I've solved all my problems
through murder because I love senpai in
case that wasn't obvious everyone I've
ever killed was because I love him so
much and because I care about him and
because he's perfect anyway so normal
everyday yandere chan here is gonna go
into school and play cupid and be a
little matchmaker for lovely lovely
rival who we don't care about very much
but you know she's alright and it just
so happens to be in case that wasn't
obvious in previous episodes our rival
is boobs McKenzie don't know why don't
know why anyone would fall in love with
her
considering how ugly she is and how our
personality sucks and I'll pretty much
everything about her is just awful and
terrible and why would anyone love a big
ol bag of ass like that that's not what
we're trying to figure out here we know
that someone in this school as rare as
it might seem actually has a crush on
boobs McKenzie don't ask me why I don't
see anything appealing about her but
maybe some loser somewhere in the school
will so what you need to do is you need
to go be friends with him and then you
need to go be friends with her I need to
have a great time doing everything else
in this school yet senpai love you
so the first thing that you need to do
is you need to not be here right now
because being right here right now means
that you're staring at senpai who is it
the digital lover little buddy hello
magical magical girl walk hey I'm
visibly armed with a magical schoolgirl
what I intended this I could never love
me
well I me that's a bit of a dish you'll
connect from the episode which is all
about love remember this episode is
about love and caring an understanding
and sharing which I was trying to do
with the magical girl wand when I shared
it with her brain come on down skedaddle
on down here yeah you're almost there no
not that door don't worry about that
door I know you're stupid but that's not
the cooking club all right so now boobs
McKenzie is gonna go over in there and
do every whatever the hell she's gonna
do no one really cares but hey hi how's
it go so I want some photograph and for
some reason this [ __ ] guy has a
British accent
Rod's a photograph of an elusive kitten
that is spotted somewhere on the school
grounds okay fine [ __ ] you I'll do that
would define someone else who shares my
appreciation for felines best of luck to
you too pip pip cheerio whatever I
parently were in Britain Japan I have no
idea what's going on but I don't care
don't go anywhere don't go to where
hey-up wait hang on meow meow meow meow
meow meow meow meow meow hey oh it's
gonna sneak back over here hopefully
he's not gone yet
that has all better not be gone yet we
live so much attempting it all this it's
never coming up I hate that talk job I
totally not like everything anyway hello
[Music]
delightful
okay good pip pip cheerio glad I could
help
go off to wherever the hell you come
from hmm
have a good day [ __ ] you anyway so back
to boobsie who's busy right now doing a
thing so I'm just gonna borrow yeah okay
all right thank you
all right anyway now that I got that
visibly lewd that's okay Hey what are
you doing over there can I talk to you
you can't talk right now
Hey
[Music]
Oh is there Oh is there nothing I just
wanna be your friend and ha burski
happily oh let melet me just show my
fingers in there that'll get my hands
ready to grab around boob Mackenzie's
neck I senpai always studying huh you're
always so handsome your [ __ ] I'm
glad you finally accepted your ugliness
you know you didn't need to be
uncomfortable being around each other we
all were aware of how hideously ugly you
were okay so now that I got that out of
the way they're both my friends right
love I know who you love someone wants
to meet you I think they're dirt I'm oh
I think don't like um probably not
though because you got heart eyes by
scent by over there and I don't want you
to nuts not senpai not at all hi
you do your thing still you weirdo yeah
yeah you better go Oh hurry love awaits
Cupid won't wait for nobody oh did I
tell the guy that he was supposed to be
there I don't think tell that guy he was
supposed to I don't think I did all
she's gonna be waiting a while isn't she
I did
oh no sorry I can't talk right now
oh I didn't tell the guy ah that's he's
probably long gone where are you oh hey
the love of your life is waiting for you
love awaits
she's at the he's found take this here
piece and go there I'll give you advice
you'll never do fail you probably do
fail but you'll never do fail right now
go girlfriend go you need to hurry the
[ __ ] up love will not wait for you
you've got to go man go
[Music]
okay now that love is about to spew
forth we can only ask what what are you
what love corn so it was right there he
was right there he was right there
trust me not a prank not one of the
pudding okay all right welcome back okay
all right okay hang on I'm gonna just I
think ya hear husky
okay now I shall make love happen
through pure manipulation which is how
love should be in my opinion that's all
I'm gonna get somebody to love me oh
you're so I guess you can say it I could
say you are beautiful I love you let's
get married let's have kids let's never
go back to this school again let's
forget about this sin pond I'm your
senpai baby all right okay negative
remark about what oh [ __ ] I didn't learn
what she liked and didn't like she
didn't really like fighting I'm okay god
damn it positive she likes cooking oh I
know I know
compliment you got great
I feel like I'm playing huniepop all
over again let's see ah your parachute
you you look okay you look sick oh [ __ ]
oh boy okay sure enough oh geez
I shove my my big brain oh boy
give gift I got nothing I was not
prepared for any of this
I was I was now prepared okay alright
goodbye All Right see ya okay alright
well that didn't go well alright then I
guess we're done you want to try again
you try the okay can't do that alright
so I'm I'm not good at this whole thing
about matchmaking considering I don't
know what human emotions are let's try
it in tomorrow let's lose code let's
circle back to it you are you both did
good good hustle out there you did great
champ yeah yeah you swung for the fences
slugger you did great you know you
should believe in yourself hey
everybody's a winner get ready everybody
you're about to see what years and years
of huniepop has done to make me a better
lovemaking man BRR
I don't know I bet you don't like
violence yeah violence is for weirdos
and murders and yon dears
okay positive I don't know theater art
art art
[Music]
okay Nord okay complement ah octo dah
you you may Dokdo dogs yeah you must
they're great ya know even your dear HN
likes octo dogs Shaw my nothingness
courage okay don't have it I stole that
I died I didn't do anything differently
this time so I guess I didn't you guys
did great out there
great hustle good job the other team you
know they may have won but pretty good
oh yeah you're gonna get smarter yes yes
you're now smart huh right you feel good
or you feel better
alright whatever whatever you feel I
don't really care but we're gonna go
tomorrow you're gonna get yeah are you
gonna really get her hmm you're gonna
really Val cosplay meet mean who doesn't
love memes who doesn't love me you don't
love memes no wonder I freaking hate you
twin drills are the best yeah okay so if
you got I got one wisdom boom boom
Shakalaka still don't have a gift but
that's okay I Baba finish okay we're
doing great doing great out there goes
great you guys are doing great you guys
are doing great doing great we didn't
get a lot of progress like I hoped it
would but you know whatever tomorrow
tomorrow is another day
tomorrow's another day champs you guys
did good you should feel good about
yourselves I mean really both together
you should feel bad about yourself for
being who you are and then the guy I
don't even know your name is we you
should feel bad about yourself for
trying to cater to someone else needs
not your own hey tomorrow kapil man
you are cute you're a cutie cutie no
one's ever called you that before huh
sure sure yes okay
science okay you don't like science
you don't like yay she doesn't like the
occult I don't know how we would have
found that out but I don't have a
goddamn gift okay sluggers all right you
you lovers you little lovers you're
gonna be lovers tomorrow I know that for
a fact
and by tomorrow I mean the magical
repeating Thursday I have to nail thee
you like school dammit you don't like
cosplay frak mastermind markiplier
masturbator
your stocking suit you yep
well okay you don't like oh nice nice
you don't like gossip hell yeah
you love family it's like we share the
same heart I know love me you have to go
oh that's too bad I would really love to
spend more time with you you can spend
forever with me you'll never bothers it
by will you did it work
I think it works right and now you're in
love forever I think you gonna go home
now
go home better not what
[Music]
snap all right so they fell in love and
they're together forever and it had a
satisfying conclusion and everyone is
happy right ok so that was the waste of
time that is love it's much easier and
much faster just to end everyone that
wants to get in the way of you and Jen
right so let that be the lesson that
everybody learns thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]